hello there everyone i'm alana and
welcome to my channel where today i am
super excited to be playing a medal of
honor above and beyond this video is
sponsored by uh it's now called meta
quest two um but if you know me you
would already know that i'm a huge fan
of the quest ii i use it all the time if
i look up you'll see my calorie tracker
that's
how much i've been playing for today
because i use uh the quest to almost
every single day to work out
so when the company basically reached
out to me and was like hey alana we want
you to play medal of honor above and
beyond it's made by respawn whom i
absolutely love um but they effectively
challenged me to try different
multiplayer modes which is something
that i have actually not done um
i think we'll probably just be playing
against spots for the purposes of this
but
i swear i'll get out there on the field
with real players at some point up until
right now i've actually only ever played
like
beat saber with one other person
um something just with one other person
usually in the same room as me actually
so this is going to be a very different
experience for me uh i did play through
a little bit of the campaign and i
played through the tutorial just to like
get a feel for the game but i don't even
really know what to expect here and i
kind of feel like it's probably going to
be
extra exciting
because
it's something about like real
physical beings like in vr it just it
just hits so different people really
physically feel like they're there and
that's already happened in the campaign
so this is gonna be our main menu
multiplayer
um so trying out like a multiplayer mode
in vr i just feel like it's gonna be
such a different experience so i am
very excited to give it all a try
okay let's check out
our characters select your character
heroes and allies
liberated acts ooh
special
unit
it's just like regular people
look at this guy
go back to portland
who do you think you are with that beard
come on now
oh oh let's be honest
[Music]
new orleans wow
oh
his name is fromage
i'm doing it my going is cheese the chef
okay
oh my gosh i love that i
there is a um a shooting range in this
which is awesome but i've not really
tried a lot of weapons so i feel like
i'm just gonna go with what it suggests
for the loadout not change anything just
yet
um and we'll go quick match
let's do
[Music]
a domination
control capture points for your team
kills also add to your team score team
with 250 points or highest points at the
end of the match wins 10 minutes that
sounds pretty standard to me
let's
do it um
it looks like i'm itching my nose right
now
and it looks like i'm actually itching
my nose from my perspective i don't i
don't know what that looks like
on your gameplay perspective but from my
perspective it's like the vr hand was
itching my nose oh i love vr
okay
in my hometown
i'm sorry about that i hope that your
hometown is okay
it's happening
okay
i i should i be scared of everybody
because i am
okay this is my team this is my team
this is my team it's fine i was like
grenade
i put it back i'll pull it back oh
that's it here we go
charlie so this is what i expected i
expected to largely be playing with cpus
oh my gosh this i already feel like 10
times more tense than i do when i join
like a
actual uh uh in in real life non-vr
multiplayer
oh it's beautiful oh
okay okay okay
so to reload this is pretty cool oh i
don't need to
be a waste of bullets
wait all right wait all that
not today
okay
y'all captain b all right go for it nope
oh i think i've died i think i have died
you hate to see it you hate to see it
hey that ktd though can we talk about
that not bad
they are all against cpus but it's fine
um i take what i can get
all right
[Music]
like if i could get a lobby full of oh
that's a friend
i feel pretty good about that
can you imagine getting a lobby full of
like people you actually fully know
how fun would that be because you can
physically see them all in their actual
movements and everything
killing it
oh y'all captain b i see i see it okay
we get rid of that hang on and this is
super cool boom and then
that yeah okay okay it's different for
every gun
oh i keep i keep running out of time
gotta stay quick on your feet you know
what i'm saying
again that ktd
it ain't all bad we're doing okay
all right
how you doing giselle
um so yeah obviously i'm playing sitting
i would recommend generally playing any
of these games expanding
but i was really stoked that it actually
was an option
in medal of honor
to let me play scene
just because i feel a little bit more
comfortable with reporting
you've got you've got a cpu andrew
you've got a cpu andrew you you you keep
a
okay i'm gonna push b again
um yeah it's cool that it has has the
option to do both and it works really
well uh either way for sure
there are also of course like a bunch of
different motion settings
range
it is much more satisfying than like why
or whatever you know oh no i'm a big
shot i got i got this i get to finally
use the storage did i use it
i used it
i'm sure i'm pulling like the biggest
game of faces right now
get out yeah
oh what are you looking at
owen hey it's all right everybody we've
kept every point out here
i'm not worried about a fang what is
this
[Music]
this seems like something that was
thrown
[Music]
no no idea what that is no idea what
that is
because we capped every point
nice
where you like where you at i hear you
but i don't see you oh oh
did they get the cap from us
we did it
we did it
thank you thank you uh it was mostly me
really carried the team
through that whole experience quite
proud of myself thank you very much
all right we're gonna jump over to blast
radius give this a shot a free for all
control points will actually be
periodically around the map gain extra
points by getting kills from inside an
act oh interesting
match ends after three control points
let's go
welcome to the rockets
maybe i could change my weapons here
let's see if i want to try something
different combat shotgun sounds fun yeah
let's do that
what is this it's a gamma bomb explodes
on impact so i was supposed to throw it
i'm gonna go three syringes
no no i'm not no i was sticking with the
grenade was sticking with the grenade
yeah now i feel good about that
because the syringes i kept not using at
the time that i should be using them
obviously
um i don't know if i finished saying
this yet there are a bunch of different
like motion settings uh i have it so
that you'll get kind of like a vignette
around it when i run just because that
makes me slightly more comfortable in vr
um
and you can have the the like quick turn
uh controls if you need them i am
definitely used to smooth turning and
don't have a problem with it um i find
it you know the most natural
experience and i'm sure it's also more
fun for people to watch
uh when it's smooth but yeah you can i
love that you just start in the room
that the menu is in that feels so cool
like i'm just physically here
me versus everyone else inside the
plastering what happened to cpu
huh today
punk oh i need to reload i haven't
thought about that hang on i don't know
how to reload this
um
maybe maybe i'm okay oh it's that okay
yes of course guns can you tell that i'm
australian
i don't know how guns work oh my gosh
this feels like
like back in the day goldeneye vibes
really just gotta remember to do that
huh
who do i need to take out that top spot
top spot is mine okay
[Music]
did i just get both of them i did
i am a god okay
not you cpu cod
where everybody i hear you but i don't
see you
i hear you but i don't see you show
yourself stay well i'm coming
oh my oh
he got me
damn
[Music]
inside that was actually really fun to
do um
catching them run feels way better when
you can move
okay
damn it's like a mob bus up there okay i
should i should heal
that was good
oh no
no
it's right here though that's good i
love that for me
okay and we gotta just stay in the point
i just know
i couldn't have gotten lucky i don't
know why
she's way too far
oh what are you guys working on
cool
a series of
targets
and a dress
i love that for you
get out not today it's not your day son
not you either cindy
you know where you belong
oh
sad
okay where are you from
i'm getting better i feel like i'm
getting better and it's very nice
to actively be aware of improvements
feels good
no no no no no no no no no no
i love that
he's too far away he's too far away
damn it aaron damn it
keep running keep running keep running
why isn't public going for the
capture point oh no
[Music]
not that helpful when it's gone
all right so clearly i'm killing that
let's try another one
mad mama free for all every player has a
timed explosive that can be placed on
any surface gain extra points for
killing enemies with your explosion and
disarming enemy explosives okay i disarm
them on them oh they placed them oh this
sounds fun let's give that a shot okay
let's go
all right
oh there it is remember to reload
oh wow okay so um
so i just have to look for bombs
everywhere this is like gonna be jump
scary
damn
oh no you gagnon no that happened real
fast okay
um
it's all right i can make that work i
can i can make it come back every player
has a timed explosive that can be placed
on any surface gain extra points
becoming enemies with your explosion and
disarming enemy explosives okay
so i should put my explosion
probably like somewhere
oh damn damn damn
woof
if you aren't thinking soupy soupy you
you really can't fall apart fast i'm not
doing so well here huh
okay
let's try again i mean oh that's
somebody's bomb probably already one of
them that's my guess
i feel like this is oh
not today
maybe
but i feel like this maybe is a bad idea
but let's give it a shot right
okay so i
i think i placed it on the wall right
before i got shot there i'm pretty sure
i think so oh that oh my gosh that will
be fun if we could hear people on like
okay
okay
anymore let's do that oh
i see damn it damn it damn it damn it he
got me
damn you chrombot
[Music]
okay y'all i'm doing pretty bad at this
one i had a couple of rounds where i
wanted to just figure it out
i wanted to just figure it out that's my
bomb that's my bomb i already placed it
did i kill anyone
damn it okay so i'm doing pretty bad at
this mode because um the issue is uh as
it turns out
thinking about multiple things in this
is i'm not ready for it yet
so i have to place this bomb
on a wall
and have it kill multiple people so
let's place it like that
then i also have to try not to die
that's going to go up for god
oh
oh my gosh it was terrible
i could have let him go and he would
have killed by the bomber and i also
have to disarm other people's bombs so
i'm looking out for other bombs
in the process of disarming bombs
feel me
damn it okay i'm bad at bomb placement
as it turns out
i feel like that probably says something
positive
in the back don't love that not my
favorite i haven't even seen a bomb to
the song where are you guys leaving your
box
i got one
okay all stern just please yes
thank you let's put it like right here
right i feel like that's funny
okay
on the wall like right here
that seems like a good bet
because people keep coming out here and
maybe it'll hurt me though
oh
not today hussein
it's gonna go off there's no one here
damn it
[Music]
did you place a bomb anyway anymore your
bomb is about to explode
i wonder if i can lure people too and
that's part of it
it's fair it's fine it's okay
[Music]
i'm making a comeback after a couple of
like pretty rough opening rounds
i am making a comeback
five kills 11 deaths
ain't so bad
let's see if i can get i just want to i
just want to get a couple more of them
take oh more syringes
i need to run away from my own wall
that's not going to kill anyone who am i
kidding
that was terrible no one is going to die
[Music]
i'll still win based on just kills alone
so it's all right i spin it man
get back here
this because it seems like an entryway
maybe
i guess when people are gonna go
this isn't looking good for me there's
so many people in the open
okay that's all right
i still haven't seen anyone's bongs to
detonate though
wow
oh i got multiple
yay
we did it oh that was bad that was bad
damn you
dorian
not again
all right
it's probably going to be my final bomb
realistically
let's go
back to syringes
take you out
not today grace
i'm in the zone right now i'm in the
zone i'm gonna get this dub
to be fair not that i was ever
threatened that i was like like that i
wasn't gonna get the job
it was in the end
another dub for team cpu alana
um
you know we've done it so yes there are
we've got team deathmatch deathmatch
domination blast radius and mad bomber
i've tried and then of course you can
just do quick match you can party up
with friends which is awesome
um it is a very fun time playing games
in in vr is such a unique experience i
never get over the excitement of trying
something new for the first time and
like feeling like the physical room
around you is actually there like it's
so cool uh highly recommend it i am
absolutely in love with my quest too so
definitely recommend you check it out
you can check the link in the
description if you want to learn more
about medal of honor above and beyond
and a huge shout out to um
meta quest for sponsoring this video
and also to respawn entertainment making
the game i'm a huge fan i'm alana i'll
see you guys next time bye